and sooner making a spot start his
second start of the year he started
against the pirates back on august 31st
nice to have a guy like suiter in your
stable to just jump in there and do the
job
good afternoon good evening and good
night to ian happ a good guy to have out
there in an emergency start suitor very
accustomed to being a starter over the
years
and he's thrown six pitches and struck
out two chicago cubs guys find
themselves behind that fastball quite
often
and he strikes out the side in the top
of the first
welcome to the ball game red suitor al
hendricks takes them out looking for a
sixth win of the year
again he began the series the season in
fine style shutting out this milwaukee
ball club on july 24 a three hitter
the next offering swing and a missed
strike three a high fastball until it's
good layoff
gonna be a tough play ureas charges bare
hand throw to first got him nice play
by luis suryas he is shining defensively
and so is the brewers defense
they committed an error last night but
that has been few and far between this
year they have been solid defensively
good pitching good defense that'll keep
you in games
and now the brewers just need to get a
little more consistent with the offense
great play by arias bare-handed able to
get him by half a step well done
how great would that be his suitor
with a
toe pick
is he all right i think so dugout loves
it he tips his cap kesten here gave him
a 10.
well brent suter had a very eventful top
of the third inning and this is what
he's
going to describe telling everybody this
is what happened how i fell down
you might have to just get a guy up
earlier than normal because suiter works
so fast good point though
foul tip strike three urias is out
well kyle not racking up the strikeouts
like suiter but moving along here nicely
through this brewer lineup
[Applause]
got him looking and a fastball on the
outside corner
he's got three strikeouts and this game
is like a quality pair of pantyhose no
runs
territory for bryant
ooh
and he ends up in the extended netting
he had some room but just unable to put
that glove out there and make the play
two balls in two strikes on braun
the pitch
this is hit pretty well deep center
field racing back his half he turns and
looks it is gone for ryan braun
a two-run shot for brawn and the brewers
strike first it's two to nothing
fastball
and he hit it out to center field and
there was little doubt off the bat that
that was gonna have a chance to fly
look at that on the change up he gets
urease
looked bad both times tonight off
hendricks
two away in the bottom half of the fifth
inning brewer's up two to nothing
hendricks looks in the pick swung on and
miss strike three
and the inning is over strikeout number
six for hendricks tonight
tobias he's one for three in the ball
game
there's the base hit the tying run will
come up
and he lines in the right
will make third
but the key man is now at first base
the cubs have a chance
jason hayward at the plate
cubs trail two nothing haters pitch on
the way to hayward swung on hit in the
air right center field and deep back
toward the wall it's got a chance that
ball is gone for a home run
jason hayward a three run homer and the
cubs lead three to two
can you believe it back-to-back hits by
left-handers against josh hader a single
in a long
long home run by hayward and the cubs
take the lead
oh my cubs 3 milwaukee two ninth inning
three two
deep they go back to back
and kimbrell
made the catch on the home run
four to two
first homer as a cop for ill demoral
vargas
unbelievable
boy i hope you didn't turn the set off
get frustrated by the lack of offense
two down runners at first and second now
jerko at second and
gamel the tying run at first
the batter is orlando arcia
right-hander to right-hander the pitch a
swing and a line drive caught at third
cubs win
vargas catches the line drive kimbrell
gets the save
what a ball game for the chicago cubs
they rally against josh hayder and they
win the game 4-2